الدكتور خبير بالشؤون الشرق الاوسط
وهو يقول ان افلام ستارز او حرب النجوم قد
تكون اقرب الى صوره الاسلام الحقيقي من
تنظيم داعش نفسه فهو يقارن علاقه لوك سكاي
ووكر مع اوبي وان كينوبي بمفهوم السلطه
الدينيه في الاسلام القائم على حسن
الاتباع كما انه يقارن فرسان الجدار في
المدرسه الصوفيه مضيفا ان هذا المشهد صور
في تونس ذات التاريخ العريق في الروحانيه
الاسلاميه والتصوف ويضيف هيل ان السيده
يعيش فيها والكهف صوره اساسيه في القران
وتتحدث عن شخصيات الخضر ويرى ان لولا
السيد يودي الاخضر ليس مجرد صدفه اما
فرسان الجدار فهم في سيطره كامله على
انفسهم وعلى غيرهم ووعيهم لانفسهم ولا
محيطهم يشبه كثيرا مفاهيم الروحانيات
الاسلاميه اما شخصيه دارث فيدر فهي ترمز
الى الشر ويشبه هذه الشخصيه بابي بكر
البغدادي الذي نصب نفسه خليفه لتنظيم داعش